c'est un petit bout d'un grand projet
l'ale gabriel est construite en 10 771
pensé par ange jacques gabriel aussi
créateur de l'opéra royal
l'architecte propose pendant 25 ans des
projets au roi mais son projet était
beaucoup plus ambitieux il s'agissait de
reconstruire totalement le coeur du
château de versailles de supprimer tout
ce qui pouvait rappeler le premier
château le château briques et pierres
de louis xiv pour donner une harmonie à
la façade un chantier stoppé par la mort
de louis 15 en 1774 comme ce grand
projet l'exposition architecture rêver
révèle les idées qui n'ont jamais été
réalisé le château a servi de lieu
d'inspiration du xviie jusqu'à l' empire
le dessin architecture peut être du très
beau dessin c'est aussi l'un des
objectifs de l'exposition c'est de
montrer finalement ces dessins qui sont
souvent peu connus qui sont exploitées
par les historiens pour leurs intérêts
on va dire historique intellectuelle
mais qui ne sont pas montrés finalement
pour eux mêmes pour leurs qualités
esthétiques
près de 120 dessins sont rassemblés des
dessins d'architecturé des plans des
projets parfois ambitieux comme cette
utopie détiennent louis vous les
architectes du xviiie siècle
son projet est véritablement d'avancé
considérablement la façade est de
supprimer tout ce qui visuellement bloc
cette vue sur la façade
il élargit considérablement l'avant
cours
il supprime les ailes des ministres l'un
des projets les plus grandioses estimé
alors à près de 14 millions de livres
des utopies et des réalités qui donne un
autre regard sur le palais